みなさんこんにちは
浮上かと申します終了車します度胸ですね置かれた数で作力ということで
あの話をさせてもらえます僕がやっている経験からですね
置かれた策をくれたば制作力って何だろう
お話をさせてもらおうと思いますよく僕ですねこういう風に話をさせて頂き館多いです
がよくステージのでて
するとよく言われるのはあれプロフィール写真と違ったような
でかい
マルイ
よく言われますそのとおりです
あの人がとつも取れば人は育ちますんでそういう助言前写真なんですよね
ちょっとー
よ写真です完璧なん
され越冬と話すはですね価値観と
テーマ赤ちゃんと体も卒業その交差点で自分の夢とか志は生まれるって話をしていこう
と思います
こんな丸くて大きい僕なんですけども一応仕事はですね
共通するアドバイザーで仕事をして今すごく真面目です
あの自治体ですとかあとはの教育委員会だとか
高校学校のスタート後にらめっこしながら真面目に仕事をしております
できな僕らがやっているのは辺境でですね
離島中山間田舎ですねそういうところで教育改革を行っています
日本には3688校公立高校があります
なんですがこの数わかりますかね
1年間に60校統廃合されています
このまま行くと6校に1校は10年にはなくなってしまうんですね
で統廃合された10日で人口が半減になったそんな
で自体も実はあるんですなので学校がなくなるというのは実は
窒化せいか地方にとっては非常に大きい問題なんですね
僕らがやってるのは特に高校なんですけど高校の魅力化プロジェクト
やっています
生徒がいきたい保護者が行かせたいそういう魅力ある高校にしていこう
いや彼の高校李東潤さんからここそういう高校にしていくそういう取り組みです
まずは方向ですね
地域の文化を生かした授業その地域でしかできないその高校でしかできないそういう
授業をやっていこうとしています
あとはまあ田舎なくなかなか塾がないから進学とかあとは学力とか心配だというふうな
まあ声もあったので後衛の宿ですね長が町が
塾を作るってが声塾行っています
あとは教育料といってまぁ量でこう
自滅する全人教育をするリーダーシップです
それは教育でやっています
この3本馬車でその地域の高校を魅力的にしていってまぁ人がどんどん少なくなって
しまうのを増やしていこうとで高校維持していこうという活動も全国なっています
まずその一番最初モデルになったのが島根県隠岐島前高校
で高校です海士町的とかありますかね海士町聞いたことでした
さすがですねそうですねはいどこにあるかというところ日本地図が発揮食いたいんです
よねっ
を切っ
この島根県きた60分あります
であの同然地区というのがありまして当然地区は星の砂長はもうちょい自分村
まあ3つのアンチができます
デコあの星の星印のとこに高校があるんですけども
人口減少の3分の1になりました阿波著
そして超少子高齢化です
財政
この39なんですねそうすると中学生の数もどんどん減っていって10年間で3分の1
になりました
そして場前候補に入ってくる生徒もどんどんどんどん減り続けて地域技術で高校1個
しかない高校が統廃合を聞きになってしまったんです
この地域から高校なくなってしまったらもう本土に行くしかありません
一人暮らしをしないという精神で経済的なかかってしまうんですね
そして高校なくなったらまさに
就業人口と子育て自体がなくなってしまうと少子高齢化がどんどん進めしまうんです
ダブルピンチャーチャンスだと考えても浜町そして行前高校魅力化のスターチでした
まあ田舎というのは課題先進国も率のか大山地域ですね
なので日本全国にくる問題が今起きています
これを題材に学べないか
日本全国の問題これが起きていくそれが今起きてるところで学べないか
次回中は最高の教材であると
いうことで
ここで教育が始まりました
巡行現象ですとか少子高齢化剤せーなー
この39日本の課題の最先端最善生です
しかも人も物も金もない
これを切り開いたらに本気で来なければよかってこれ本気で甘茶をさせたんですね
聞いた瞬間中島中で変な宗教やってるのかなって思っちゃいました
でも本店釣れちゃったらすごいなと思うんですけども
ためしまって社会の縮図なんですよね全て揃っています
すべてる揃っていてそのすべてにおいて日産日本にい30年後に来るだろう問題に戦っ
ている大人たちがいる
そういうときは話が聞けてかつ操作すると戦える
こりゃいい教育ですよ
bye bye あの声自分の耳蝉って字が入っていました地域の問題が課題でして
それを入れた教材にして話し合いながら自分指輪考えてい
技術箇所形になっていますこれ痩せていた時の僕ですね
ちょやっぱり4年前に出せません
なかなかこういうあの教育アメリカされなかったんですよなんでこんなことする意味
あるのっていうことを
結構言われましたでも生たちはついてきてくれて
実際育っていきました
今ではあの高校魅力化の目玉の一つになっています
こんなに増えたんですよねしかも外国人も参加していて英語で夢墨とか
やっています
であの子いう風な強行する課税高からおいでという数字からですね
全国から生徒が来てくれて締まるよと言うので来てくれて
そう言うと彼にはになりました
制度が2倍になって共有も増えて部活も増えました
ガッキーも増えました一楽で1学期だったのが1だけで身勝手になりました
手下もですねあのー島外から半分所ているんですね
東京東北ドバドバ5
ドイツ
日本人です日本人で日本人がこうおっしゃっています
あとあの進学もですね家庭ですねもうそれまでも大学とは別にいいし見たい目的ないし
っていうのが目的を持って上を目指すようになってきました
大学進学するなってきました今では国公立ねそかは避けようですがそういうところに
受かるような高校になってきました
そういうふうな教育環境が良いんであればということで子どもが増えています
若者が増えていますどんどん移住して人が今日てますねどんどんどんどん高
この地方消滅と言われるおり
人口増えてるんですね
今ところ分かりいいですかね日本地図なんですけどもこういう風な高校見るか全国で
あの始まっています
僕ではいらしていているイクア部が安いいただいているいくつかが孝行できたかなと
思うんですが
作家移動ですとか長野県広島県
沖縄県ですね見ていきましょう
まずは国会の羽幌町天売高校
けれども
ここなります
すごいですね
であの350人しか住んでませんでも上で役は見ています
と見入ったり人が住ましてもらってそういう高校です全校生徒4人の国でした
どこに良いたからはあるんですよ高校生はシルマ働いて
ログ昼間働いて夜勉強するんです
生徒4人対処先生82ました
その個別指導
なので知れば働きながらキャリア教育よりはきちんと勉強
で稼いだお金を使って自分自身がツールです
自分で自立精神的経済的自立していく良い環境ですよね
これ日本全国に広げましょうと言いました
これは沖縄久米島みんな去っ作ることが必要
根拠
こういうところですね
えあの子にありますまた辺境ですね100キロぐらいですねまぁ一こけ30分ものです
こんな感じですよココアの琉金オープンになるまでは実は
一つの国家でした一つの勢力範囲だったんですね
食の文化もすべてあの貿易の経済の全て
自立してみませんだから自立しようというそういうふうな文化かあるんですね
最近の家族ちいせーなんくるだなぁ
なんかよ大丈夫なんですランクルなら自分でなんとかせんといかんということを今
キメジ本気出しちゃう
そういうところで教育ですとか再生エネルギーですとか
海洋深層水そういうのを使ってコーチ島を樹立させていこうという街の動きに高校生が
参加するそういうものを使用しています
大阪女島本当にこんな今日サーブのがいいですよもちろん
朝のイメージですね
ここはですね
私はですね
村上水軍の流れを汲んでいるところですねなので行
海賊水上追軍海賊たちの松江がいます
この撮影ですね
も5まで床に横にいるんですよ
声で村上スイングてですねまあもちろん州のまあ市本塩目です海の子思いますんでその
潮目を読む力櫛枝というのも今後の社会を読む
まあ4勝目シャル坂梨読む読む力にしていこう
その潮目が来てもになっています
受けてみたいですよねどうなるのか
装備が教育をしています
開けば
すごいですねアルプスになります
けれどもここにあります山か海たんですよ
大脳ここはスキー場で有名なんですけども今スキー場
実は外国人たくさん来ているんですね
で冬に入るとこが外国かと思えるぐらいです
でそれを求めていろんなですね外国人も実は進み始めていて
実際もう日本人の結婚してもそこへ提携定住してるんですね
まあそういうのまで外国人が多いんであれば観光と英語オーソライズ語と英語で観光
国際規格作りました
その地域で学べることっていうのは高校までに入れていこうと思います
その結果
全校生徒よりの高校になんと3人入りました
年ぶりの入学し
羽倉高校
入学者無中にんぐ55人から7人に増えました
さっきの海賊の島大阪医専高校
17年から31に変えました2倍ですよ
小島高校
55人から87人に増えました
40年ぶりに行けないように5 v ですかって聞いたら
雪が降ったプリってきます
マイ者庁はも随分ん
何も大學語文っていうのですね言ってみれば
それ里に誇りを持つ高校生が増えたということは成果と思います
じゃあなぜこの問題を病んだと理系だった特売
まず選んバーガーを得られるというのは選択肢と
洗濯時間が出来ですね
塾がないと入れませんたくさん選択違う
じゃあその洗濯事件何かというと価値観です
価値観というのは物事の判断する基準です
北の勝タンは一体何なのか反証します僕はない藤岡シーンって今さっき言いましたよね
実はの長男ですでもになんです
あの複雑な家庭環境でございんですよ
うちの母の教えで一番になるんじゃなくて一番うちに追い続けろという挑戦し続ける
っていう名前をつけられます勝手に
もうちょっとなくしたかったですね人生
米小学校という宇宙飛行士じゃなかったんです
別の見てました衛星放送である日の前では勝ちました
は数軒ありました
持ってるしたんです
そしたら家の箱やられましたもしあなたが本当に宇宙飛行士になって乗っていてもし
死んでしまって私は横分
それ一体どういうことですか聞いたら家の母親と言いました
上を持ってこれ等を果たして
c のダンスと本会なりとん
ああああああ
車1女ですね
北校今度いられるそうなんですよ
で3回戦以来で負けるチームの間ですよね場合1階です試合ですごい通知
もう日本で優勝つんじゃないか最初の半分は日本代表というチームはです
戦うことなんです皆運びました大虐殺できる始まるみたいな
で行ったんですよねもうみんなの遺言ゾード大切みたいです
気がする際のレベルじゃないんだ
実際穴を言ってみたらみんなデカイ
でもどうしてどうします
彼は蔵くらあの監督がありました
何でもまぁそんな彼は青い波がそれは多い
考えてみると相手は高校生です染色体性美人2倍じゃないし
筋肉建て債務3倍斬馬剣も叩かんじゃないんだと同じ高校さんは何で勝手にその天井を
つけて限界を作っているのだ
まつげないからから問われて皆ハッとしました
あのーラグビーで実際にシャイする時エンジン気分ですけどその時人という目線みんな
その時行ったほうが自分の限界を吹く低俗
ぜひ臨みましたこれ着てきて買ったんですよ
やればできるんですね
まあ土木な価値観はめちゃ無理か靴だしたい
こういう価値観になってきました
めちゃにこれ大好きなんです
無理だってもらうと思えちゃう
そうして作っ
大学院卒業した後社会人経験ゼロでそして人目弦起業しました
いろんなして無理だって言ってましたむちゃんってもらいました考えな音声です
もどってこういうとこにもだかわかりません言われました
でも頑張りました蒼頡は今もう11年目です
5仕事の中で鉄は隠岐島前高校との出会いがありました
統廃合すん山高校を引っ掛けるプロジェクトに参加してほしいって
和祐君あの高校魅力化をリーダーですね
言われたんです
全裸いろんなプロジェクトですよね面白そうと思います
会社を運営しながらこれできるかな移住してほしいたと思う
つまりくん
いろんな子と話したんです妄想ですよねセラーじゃあ絶対見たほうがいい
キャリイを棒に振るよってを述べました
でもメジャー取りだって言われたんですだからやってみようと思ったんですね
メジャー振りだっているとお伝えしたいスレ bicycle ん
結局先を統制とする2倍になって今団第有名なきます
そしたらいろんな高校から自治体からやってほしいかけたんです
ちょっと僕の恐れさせない悩みました他のここできるのか悩んでました
そしたら家の家宝でバックも写真送ってきたんです
わかるかと
わかるんですよね家中谷60歳超えて天井に試験を勉強して受かって日本人もあって
ですね
あなたは島根県とか東京大きくしてなんか悩んでるけども私は日本人もあっているんだ
と情けなくないかと
その辺です
入って今全国の高校の魅力化をやっています
かつ自分を夢志堂できるか
自分の価値観がありますそして自分の価値観
あってそして自分の前いろんなテーマがあります職業だとかもん万博のテーマがあり
ます
その
横軸縦軸価値観縦軸そしてこの者官邸前5色ですね
この交差点目こそ自分の夢とか
心たちが生まれるんじゃないかなと思って
選択肢だけあっても自分の
価値観がないと
いられないんですね
だから価値観とテーマそして職業交差点解明子たちは生まれると思います
価値観スチルヒントは親です御簗は長い込めた想い口癖
猿の女
そして自分の際の音尊敬するトーセイビル好きな言葉つけ箸なるんです
国会自分8感が生まれていくと思っています
価値観っていうのはスポーツをする夢はこれの巣をきっかけだと思っています
それこそがこれでも制作
つまり環境のせいにするんじゃないんですよね
自分の軸を持って今の環境でできることを探していく
そうすることができれば自分の夢子たちができるとそれが作れると思っています
どうも始めました